Congrats to you tonight.
I just want to note that once again,
Donald Trump cost my party Senate seats.
I was advising these same Georgia
runoffs in 2020
when he lost those seats
by touting the election lies
when it was Perdue and Kelly Loeffler.
Once again,
he put his hand on the scale
and put up a candidate
who's highly unqualified
Herschel Walker to be in the U.S. Senate.
And so now we are in a position
where we have to come around and realize
we are not even merely losing under him.
The fact that in Biden's economy,
how poorly the country is doing,
the fact that by and large voters, right,
left or center
say we're on the wrong trajectory,
yet they're not voting for change.
That since 1934
that they have
not actually
had an incumbent
not lose seats in the Senate.
That is an indictment
of the Republican Party
we need to wake up because we are losing.
Can I just say something about voters
here in this whole midterm election
we saw a lot of split tickets.
People were voting for candidates.
They were not just voting up
and down the line.
They were taking a look
at a candidate's character and experience
and saying, you know, I want this person,
you know, I'm going to vote
for the Republican governor
in New Hampshire.
That's great.
Yeah, it's a
it's a it's a development
in this country.
You know,
there are a couple of states
that are famous for it, Montana
being one of them.
But it doesn't happen
all the time in this country.
And now
I think this is a great development.
People are paying attention
because the stakes are so high,
especially if we keep talking
about candidate quality.
And we only talk about it
on the Republican side
saying they have negative
but I just want to say,
you know better,
why not is an extraordinary human being.
There's a reason he's recognizable
in our community.
As somebody who was working
hard for people when he wasn't famous,
working hard for people when he was name,
was always believing in these causes
when they were not popular
and so he's somebody who has a resonance
that he has with people.
People believe him.
And and I just
I don't want to only be
you had a bad guy on the Republican side.
You had a good man
on the Democratic side nationally.
And he didn't change.
He didn't he could have
dragged Herschel Walker
through the end zone,
through the whatever.
What I was looking
what you got,
but he could have dragged him.
There was so much material,
but he was a man of character and said,
I know who I am
and I'm going to run the race.
Now. I did.
I'm I like my negative ads.
They did.
They did run their fair
share of negative ads.
50, 60, $70 million
in character smashing.
And so it wasn't
it wasn't a clean campaign.
They could have been a lot.
They did what they had to do.
But I think I think on Van's point,
one thing I learned about this
entire election,
people with personal brands apart
from somebody else,
did well in both parties.
Warnock had a brand apart from politics,
but the camps and the DeWine's
and the DeSantis
and the Abbotts and the Republican Party,
they didn't depend on Donald Trump
or some other person
to define who they are.
And I do think this ticket splitting,
Gloria,
there's something about being able
to define and own who you are
that people are responding to.
They don't want you to be
a wholly owned subsidiary
of some other person or thing.
They just want you to be who you are
and we're not.
And you got that right in this race.
Walker got tagged with with Trump
and the candidates in these Senate races
that got tagged that way with Trump
all across the board lost.
And that's a big lesson for the next.
Like every Republican in this country
ought to hold Donald Trump
accountable for this.
And I think
the part that bothers me
the most
and I spent a lot of time
trying to dissect this,
is that Donald Trump,
it's not out of ignorance
or miscalculation.
It's out of selfishness.
He's not picking these candidates
because he thinks it's
good for the country or the party.
He gave up caring about this country
when he lied about the election.
He cares about himself
in these candidates.
That he's picking our pawns
and he's playing a serious game
and he's costing us an economy.
As a Republican,
I'm watching a crumbling economy.
I'm watching a foreign policy
I'm watching a border.
These are things I care about
for my future, my kids future.
That's why we're all in this game.
And we need to hold Donald
Trump accountable.
And I hope sooner than later
he's in the rearview mirror.
We need to use this
as a pivot point
for us to move forward
with a GOP 2.0 or call it what you want.
We need a new direction
that allows us to capitalize
on on the short term and very well said.
And I think that I just want to issue
the word of caution
that we have seen Donald Trump
come back from the ashes many times.
He did poorly in these midterms,
the insurrection.
He comes back
and as the leader of the party,
it needs to be a wake up moment
the way that you believe in.
Raphael Warnock,
I want candidates on the Republican side
that I believe in that way.
And that is just not
we put up in some of these races
so it's time to have that moment of
are we going
to keep losing with Donald Trump?
Are we going to move on?
You know, the strategy,
the Trump strategy
was that
the waters would part for him
after the midterm elections
and of course, just
the opposite has happened,
not to mention his legal problems,
not to mention throwing aside
the Constitution, etc., etc.
If Republicans
don't have the guts to separate,
if not divorce
at this point,
I mean, Republicans in leadership roles,
not not rank and file,
I mean people leading,
then there's a problem.
There's a good group
of candidates out there.
As you were talking about, Scott,
the question is where the followers
are going to be.
And I think followers want to win
if they believe in
what the Republican Party stands for.
They want to win party leaders.
By the way, we've done this historically.
They beat Republican party leaders
need to come together and decide
how much do we want to lose?
Are we willing to band together?
And, by the way,
not run 15 or 20 people in 20, 24
put our money
and our efforts
behind a couple of people
who can actually be
you're going to have to be honest
with the voters.
You're going to have to say
that Donald Trump lied to them.
And that means that at times
you lied to them to
and I don't know
if many Republicans and leaders
are going to actually want to do that.
Well,
on the Democratic side,
I push you to let that just hang
hey,
Mike, there's a difference
between want to and need to, right?
People might not want to say
that they made a mistake
and they followed down a rabbit trail
about an election fraud
and conspiracy theories and,
you know,
all their different nuances
in their states.
But we need to
win to heal and rebuild this party.
We need to move
past Donald Trump and call it
for what it is. It was a mistake.
And we need to move on with any of
the prominent Republicans
in the Senate have
who once opposed Donald Trump
sold their souls in order to curry favor.
And so how do they bounce back from that?
I mean, we've been talking
about redemption and grace,
and I believe in all of that.
But this is still politics, right?
And so people there,
what does that have to do
with redemption and grace?
People, I
want to talk about our party
that is a little better think.
I just don't think
people are
the thieves haven't partied,
but they haven't also drowned.
Donald Trump
and it's because folks are not sure on
where they want to fall.
And the truth telling
that is going to have to happen around
why Donald Trump was able
to get these type of candidates
to win in primaries
and why he was able
to get a mob of people to come on
January six requires some real honesty
that I don't know exists
in the Republican leadership.
Maybe it does.
I'm hopeful for my country.
I'm hopeful, but I haven't seen it yet.
I mean, he
he talked about terminating
the Constitution a couple of days ago.
And and there's still a lot of
I've lived
I've lived through all these undulations.
And you're right, he has come back.
I just telling you, in the last month,
something has changed.
I feel that something has changed.
And you had a number of
people in Washington,
but you've got people out
in the middle of the country saying,
you know what, I'm glad he was there.
I liked what he did. I voted for the man.
I knocked on doors,
but I don't want to lose anymore.
And I'm tired of carrying
this guy's bags.
And this has been one of the worst months
of his political life.
I'm telling you, something has changed.
And that's what primaries before.
You're right.
That's what primaries are for.